we all know these people that want to
just
like tell you their darkest secret which
is they wake up every day and they like
dream of quitting
like they have fantasies of quitting
every day
those are people that
probably should quit
[Music]
this is michael cybel with dalton
caldwell and today we're talking about
how to break out of fame
i think almost inadvertently
because we talked to so many young
technical people young technical
founders and potential founders we've
become experts at career advice
and specifically big tech career advice
which i don't know about you dalton it's
not an expertise i ever wanted to
develop at all
yeah i mean
i've never worked at a fang like this is
probably the last thing i'd be
interested in talking about with people
but man
we get exposed to lots of this stuff
and i think what's interesting is that
technical founders often misunderstand
the value they can get out of feng
and
misunderstand is an understatement they
grossly
misunderstand
what value they can extract from a fang
job and what value they can't extract i
think mostly because a lot of founders
are mixed in with other people with
different motivations right most people
want to be managers or employees
i think a lot of founders have friends
who want to be managers employees and
they kind of like see those people
attracted to fang and they assume
all those things apply to them as well
whereas you know as we both know the
founder path's quite different than the
employee path yeah it's funny i remember
when i was an undergrad
a lot of the recruiters the people that
had the the most recruiters and the best
recruiters tried to create cachet i
remember you know when i was in school
it was all around management consulting
was the high status
cool jobs to get
and um
it was a certain kind of person that
would like fall for that that like
working at mckinsey or accenture or
something was like the cool thing to do
and what's funny is at the time google
was like an 80 person startup and they
were trying to recruit on campus but it
was like i would have cared do you want
to be different like it was exactly the
opposite brand of what of what google is
now because there was just kind of a
grubby little startup um but the point
is
it's easy
it's easy to look at folks that employ
the most recruiters
um
and and use that as your basis like
whoever has the best booth at the career
fair whoever gives out the coolest stuff
and and make your selection that way
right if that's if that's the criteria
you used to select what college should
go to which is like oh whatever has the
best rankings you look at the best
career rankings for where to work after
college and that's going to drive you
towards
you know
google facebook whatever right
it's not crazy i get i get why this
happens and if you want to be an
employee or a manager in a large tech
company
that's great like that's correct
in fact i'd argue all those guides are
written for you and it makes sense to
write guides for you because you're the
vast majority of people
the problem is
what should the founders do what should
the potential founders do what should
the future yeah
people that are curious founder curious
people the people that might want to
maybe they're like oh start i think
that'd be cool what's their move exactly
so
let's start with some of the assumptions
that we hear from these potential future
founders
about why working at fang right out of
college or soon thereafter makes sense
why it's
and and it never it's never presented us
to us as like it's a pretty good
opportunity it's always presented to me
at least as like oh of course it's
essential it's an essential part of the
state of fact they're stating facts
that's like we must work so here's the
first one we hear a lot
um
before a car i start a company i want to
get experience
working on the hardest technical
problems at the largest scale
and fang is the only place in the world
to do this
what do you think dalton that is that's
just quoting the recruiter
[Laughter]
you're like you're like reading the
you're reading what the recruiter's line
is i mean look most people that get most
jobs at fangs when you talk to them
after the job if they're you know get a
couple of beers in them
they're working on some [ __ ] ad
server they're working on like one pixel
on one corner of one thing they're
working on some project that's going to
get killed
like
again if if you're someone that's like a
good enough programmer to get hired to
work on some deep technical
infrastructure google then this line is
true but most folks that i talk to at
least
kind of have what is like
a shitty job but that's been presented
in brand to them branded to them is a
very cool
thing and again this is marketing like
they want you to take the job they want
you to keep the job and someone's got to
do all the crappy ad server work right
someone's got to
and so if you actually look at the
numbers way more folks that you meet
that work at a fang job have the
equivalent of like some shitty ad server
like buttons or translating into foreign
languages or something just like the
worst job android settings and the
people
then the people that are working on the
core search infrastructure at google
which again that actually sounds really
cool and that is working on hard
technical problems the larger scale you
know so i think you just want to be
honest about what the job actually is
and not just
quote the recruiter
well and let's be clear the way that you
actually learn what the job is is you
talk to someone doing it you don't talk
to the recruiter like
i think maybe people don't quite
understand how the entire job of the
recruiter and the number one they get
way they get paid promoted
everything
is convincing you to sign up
yeah they get comped per person it's
just
it's like a car salesman they don't make
money if they don't sell their car if
they don't if you don't sign on the
dotted line they're not getting paid
um the next one is
dalton and this is a little a little
more vague like it's going to be easier
for me to be successful at my startup
i'm going to learn important lessons i
can apply to my startup
if i work for a while at fang
right because the lessons i learned at a
big company can directly apply to my
early stage startup right isn't that how
it works
look
i think in some situations folks that
are really green
can learn a lot about working on a team
and having a manager
learning about how corporations work
learning about politics it's a great way
to learn about politics
but you'd be surprised at how many
founders that we talk to
will tell you that nothing they did in
their job
translates at all to their startup like
could not be less relevant versus their
college coursework was more relevant
isn't that weird like and it's because
in a lot of things you have so much
tooling again i'm talking about
programmers here but you have so much
infrastructure inside of google or
facebook to do your job and they have
their own way of doing code reviews like
there's just all this stuff so when you
start a startup and you have none of it
and you're starting from scratch
you're like wait
what happened to all those tools i was
used to using and bigtable and bigquery
and all you know whatever whatever you
had yes and you like
you're dependent on those tools
and so it's a lot more like doing a
college project again where you kind of
have there's no tooling there's no
infrastructure you have to create
everything from scratch and so again
what's funny is like you know you learn
a lot of stuff but a lot of what you
learn is how to use the tools of the
fang
which you don't get to use when you
don't work there anymore
get what i'm saying again this is a very
programmer-centric point but like yes
i've seen founders run into this problem
a lot
the way that i would say this slightly
differently is that i think when you
work on fang founders find that there's
more they have to unlearn whereas like
college wasn't actually set up to help
them get products out in the wild but it
didn't give them a whole process that
they can't use
with their startup whereas like in many
ways the big companies give them a whole
process that
is just completely irrelevant from when
you're doing a company and so you have
to unlearn
i've worked with so many google
engineers who are just like
their standard for getting a product
into even beta at google
is 10x what an mvp in a startup is and
they just have to unlearn it's like
can anyone find this useful
launch
and i've had to fight with founders on
that where it's like oh well this would
never
this would never see the light of day at
google and it's like yeah that's not
that's not the standard
okay here's another one right
well
vcs they care
right like a vc is good like
we all know that google um engineers
can just raise a series a can raise five
to ten million dollars like with almost
nothing right like this is my path to
getting funded i mean
it depends on
i mean certainly depending on your
resume it could it could be helpful
right it's it's a good brand name to
have so i i don't think that's
false but i think at some point
the more time you spend there what was
once a good positive signal could turn
into a negative one
again i can't speak for all investors
but at some point you lose the shininess
of getting that validation
um as well as what team you're on and
all this other good stuff and so you
know i think there's some truth to that
is what i'm saying but like
if you stayed there for eight years that
doesn't apply anymore you kind of have
to get out to get the benefit of it
i also think there's this weird
feeling
i think people will read techcrunch and
see oh these google people are getting
funded and then the kind of assume vcs
are like walking the halls like being
like engineer here's term sheet the flow
that you walk through to work to like go
to mit and be a cs major and then get
employed at facebook is nothing like the
flow you'd work you'd walk through to go
from a facebook engineer to raising
money like these are not the same flow
and i think people really mistake those
this is one of my big talking points to
founders in the batch which is
you don't read about the unsuccessful
fundraisers
and so if all you read is the successful
fundraisers it looks like everyone is
raising and every google engineer is
raising and every
because we just never hear about the
ones that didn't happen
and so
don't fall for that
it's not that easy
you can't just wave a magic wand and
they're not just handing out you know we
say this they won't believe us michael
but like i think people actually think
they just hand out
party favors or something you know oh
yeah you worked at google like
yeah isn't there a special door at a16
you just walk in that door
present your google credentials and
money money
maybe not well that's the thing is
there's just there's a lot of google
employees and ex-googlers now do the
math it doesn't pencil out
let's talk about the trap right so so
these are a lot of assumptions that
future founders have
let's talk about on the other side
what's the company trying to do right
and i think this is something that i
hear a lot
where
the company is trying to retain you and
trying is not the right word the company
has engineered and iterated a system
over often times
a decade plus
to retain you and when you sign that
piece of paper you have to understand
you're going into the same retention
flow or retention flow
built by a company that often is trying
to retain uses on its product like it's
really good yeah it's highly gamified
it's highly gamified
oh i can get my next level michael i
want to get the
my next level upgrade and then i unlock
my booster pack founder blah blah blah
share
reward and then i get level 14 like
yeah
and one of the things that i see that
founders don't realize is how
the fangs will do this around equity so
here's a story that founders will tell
me right i'm going to get in
with some kind of signing bonus i'm
going to feel good some kind of sound
i'm going to feel good some kind of
equity package i'm going to feel good
i'm well compensated this is great
and then i'm gonna get out but of course
that equity is vesting over four years
right like you know you're in that
equity a little bit of time over four
years
so that's the first part of the trap
right it's like if you if you leave
you say goodbye to that money
the second part of the trap is that if
you're good six months in
you get another
chunk of equity but it's vesting over
four years
so think about it you've been there for
six months but there's
disproportionately more money
that you have invested yet which
incentivize you to stay a little bit
longer this is a dark pattern it's a
loss aversion which is people do a rash
if you give someone something and then
threaten to take it away they will
irrationally value it to avoid a loss
versus they never had to begin with they
won't do it again you know google this
loss of version is a thing so yes
there's a lot of
stacked lock over loss aversion around
vesting
especially because founders will think
of it as their savings and this is the
second part of the trap right
you're around a lot of people who want
to be employees and managers not
founders
oftentimes they're up styling they're
upscaling their lifestyle nicer
apartment car nicer vacation because
they want to be in this world they're
not looking to save money to start their
company right
and so the people around you start
spending money especially because they
see that vesting equity as almost
savings
so bam
you're not saving money because you're
going on instagram vacations bam you
continue to get these little equity
bonuses that vest over four years
if they can keep you spending your
entire salary and that they can keep the
money that you have invested yet larger
than the amount of money that you have
in your savings by like two to three x
you never leave like you like like your
brain tell like a rational human says
don't leave
yeah and again where's this coming from
we talk to these people and they're like
yeah
i hate my life but this is the setup
like they explain this to us
as like the reason they can't do the
thing they want to do
it's kind of sad
to talk to someone
who's like
ex they lay all this stuff out for us
and they're like and therefore
you know i can never do a startup or
something
and like they're like 25 and it's like
and this is how the math works out i
can't i can't i can't i'm not free i
can't do it in many ways
this is a defensive tactic to warehouse
talent
out of the fear that maybe someone else
can use you in a way that can hurt the
company whereas if they warehouse you on
the android setups team yeah think about
it's like speculative science projects
that get axed and that never ship like i
saw that facebook built some kind of
silicon they built a chip and then they
were like
no never mind and like they never
shipped the thing that probably people
dozens of people spent years of their
life on i saw that paypal had some kind
of research lab they just laid everyone
off this week like basically if you're
not on the core thing
you have no promises that your work will
ever turn anything and how bad does it
feel to spend five or six years and just
oh yeah we were in the moonshots group
they decided not to do our thing they
shut down our group
that sucks and oftentimes that's the
thing that got you to sign
right that was the thing oh like i would
have never worked on the normal thing it
was the moonshot so
if you're getting ta if you're technical
and you feel like you're getting trapped
here dalton like how do you know it's
time to get out like how do you know
like okay like
or even if you see a friend in this
situation how do you know it's time to
tell them like hey like hey
think about breaking up
i think for the people that i talk to
which again it's it's probably not a
representative set of the average it's
probably the people that are more
disgruntled but um
to the extent
that you have conversations where it's
like talking to someone
that's like an alcoholic and it's like i
gotta stop drinking like i can't do this
anymore
again i'm trying to be funny but it's
like when someone's just like i don't
know why i'm doing this but i'm still
doing it and i can't stop but i hate my
life like like if that sounds like you
or your friend talking about your job at
facebook that's probably a good sign you
maybe shouldn't do it anymore
and
and the actual tactical thing you do is
keep your personal burn low so you can
do it and not get hooked on the money
with all this gamification we talked
about
and realize you can always come back
if you're a good programmer if you're a
good programmer and you leave and you
leave in a nice way no matter what
happens to you you can come back there's
actually not that much loss you have to
take and so versus the people that are
like no this is cool i like my life yeah
stay there right this this message is
not for you but we all know these people
that want to just
like tell you their darkest secret which
is they wake up every day and they like
dream of quitting
like they have fantasies of quitting
every day
those are people that probably should
quit and it's interesting because we're
probably talking to
like one percent
of the developers at fang companies like
one percent for like 99 developers at
fantom is irrelevant this is this is not
relevant yeah this is not for you we're
not we're not trying to argue with you
right we're just saying
though if you know someone that's deeply
unhappy because of decisions they're
making they can just make different
decisions
you can tell them that you can break the
spell
you can break the spell so to wrap up
right like
the fang optimization i think there's a
couple kind of takeaways here like i
think the first one is that like if
you're technical and you want to be a
founder
um
and you decide that faying is the the
right part for you the right path for
you at least to start
um a couple things you should be
thinking about one is
how long you're going to stay
right like how can you stay
for long enough to get the value without
getting trapped
so if you get trapped your plan goes to
[ __ ] it sounds like the second one and
you were touching on this like
don't work on projects that will like
make you hate your life make you hate
tech like cause you to decide to just
become like a a nomad who roams like you
know
weird beaches in southeast asia like we
know these people like
yeah like
i know a lot of ex-facebook people
who kind of like feel that they did evil
and they made money doing it
and they seemed pretty unhappy about it
they're not happy about the work that
they did in the universe and so yeah
don't don't do that like like the
psychic scars of doing that stuff
is is expensive
well and it'll prevent you from being
optimistic about tech which you need to
be if you're going to be a startup
founder like you need to be optimistic
i say the last one is
have a plan at the start
like know what you're trying to
accomplish you're trying to get a visa
you're trying to save money are you
trying to get this on your resume have a
plan for what you're trying to
accomplish by taking one of these jobs
and a plan for when you want to leave
it's a lot easier to have a plan when
you're not
looking a bonus in the eye
right if you come in with the plan when
the bonus thing happens you'll see it
coming if you're fighting the bonus head
to head with no plan
bonus wins most of the time
all right with that that's how to break
out of fang thanks dalton
thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you